salut aujourd'hui j'ai une vidéo avec
une invitée on va discuter de quelque
chose de ces passionnants mais j'ai pas
mon pied de caméra je n'ai pas pris
heureusement j'ai toujours un pied de
caméra de secours serrage au tout début
de l'année quand je me suis lancé sur
youtube
la première personne qui est venu me
voir en spectacle et qui était un peu de
youtube gay mais qui m'a contacté c'est
laetitia de la chaîne le corps la maison
l'esprit c'est une meuf minimaliste donc
l économie c mort on verrait alors en
quelques mots c'est quoi la définition
pour toi du minimalisme en fait il ya
plusieurs définitions du minimalisme
mais globalement quand et minimaliste tu
essayes de vivre avec le moins de choses
possibles et de simplifier au maximum
donc le moins de choses matérielles
moins de choses matérielles or souvent
le minimalisme on le voit d'un point de
vue matériel au minimalisme à moi il est
plus au niveau de ma manière de vivre
globalement et au niveau de ma manière
de penser manière ma manière de
réfléchir des choses qu'est ce qui se
passe pour une meuf par exemple à partir
du moment où elle achète peut être
élevée en fait c'est hyper intéressant
parce que si tu veux quand t'es une
fille tu es dans la rue était tout le
temps sollicité en permanence tu vois
irait il ya des boutiques
il ya des sites à acheter quand tu es
dans un magasin tu regarde tout le temps
les choses puis c'est à cette espèce de
truc de te dire je vais peut-être que je
vais quelque chose et ça te prend
énormément d'énergie et en fait moi un
jour j'ai décidé de ne plus rien acheter
je me suis dit bon mais pour cette
saison
j'achète pas je garde ce que j'ai et
puis j'ai fait une saison j'ai fait une
autre saison j'étais notre saison est là
maintenant j'en suis agence 6 bientôt
sept ans je vois sans rien acheter
et en fait ça libère complètement mon
esprit et ça me fait économiser
énormément d'énergie au quotidien
manquant je suis dans la rue il n'y a
rien qui attire mon attention y'a aucun
magasin qui attire mon attention j'ai
pas envie d'acheter
ça me prend je n'ai plus envie de
rentrer dans un magasin tu vois quand je
suis dans un magasin ça me prend trop
d'énergie je ne peux plus et quand tu
dis que ça te fait économiser d'énergie
c'est physique mais ceux-ci mentale du
coup exactement
en fait je me suis rendu compte que tu
vois au quotidien on fait des choix tout
le temps on est sollicité en permanence
et le fait de limiter mes choix au
minimum eh ben ça me permet de garder
mon énergie pour les choix qui sont
importants tu vois par exemple le matin
devant mon armoire moi je veux pas ça
quinze mille questions si j'ai acheté
plein de vêtements si j'avais plein de
vêtements je réfléchirai à convaincre je
m'habille il faut comme en août soit
sorti avec mon pantalon
j'étais comme ça avoir commencé à sortir
avec mes chaussures qui soit directement
maquillage qu'il soit sorti avec mon sac
tout ça tout ça maintenant je vous mets
en moi j'ai pas beaucoup d'amis je
prends ce que j'ai je le porte
généralement c'est très simple est ce
que l inverse tu prends les choses au
premier degré parce que tu as décidé que
tu n'étais pas concerné par ce mode de
communication la bassine avec moi je si
j'essaie de te faire un sous-entendu
gens c'est un mode vient faire une vidéo
à la tempête
est ce que toi tu es ce que toi tu va
analyser les double langage en disant à
temps il me dit ça parce qu'en fait il
veut ça le chef des bills au nom
gsm/edge les comités monde fabien oui
moi on savait déjà
donc ça avait déjà créé la intéressante
la question que je sais pas comment
répondre je crois qu'en fait je me pose
pas énormément de questions je vois je
prends le truc comme ça vient je crois
que je me trompe pas souvent sur les
gens et sur l'intention mais je ne vais
pas réfléchir dit milan ac est ce que
veut la personne mais est ce qu'il m'a
dit ça parce que ça parce que ça même
dans mon enfin même dans mon rapport à
l'autre quand il a inversé faut que ce
soit simple et c'est par contre les gens
qui sont pas simples j'ai tendance
effectivement les états ni moi parce que
par exemple dans le projet du vainqueur
oui si vous n'avez pas vu toutes ces
vidéos aussi vous avez vu mais vous êtes
peut-être pas reconnu laeticia
c'est elle qui a parlé au président de
la commission européenne sur le projet
dumont coeur etc
je donne en paraître a envie de temps il
en était de poursuivre on est ça qui la
suivait forcément il a fallu tu te
détecte en fait quel était le désir
de youtube de la commission européenne
de tout ça pour pouvoir agir contre tu
vois ce que les lianes ça démontre une
forme d'intelligence pour une fois alors
atteint c'était une chance et au hasard
j'étais très bien entouré je me suis
retrouvé dans des situations de ces
piles cet exemple là on est en face d'un
mec était un lobbyiste rajhi moi qui me
disait quelque chose et à la fin de la
conversation
j'avais compris un truc rade j'avais
compris un autre truc et on a dû
regarder les images plusieurs fois pour
se rendre compte que j'avais tort
j'étais vraiment mais alors été très
bien entouré et du coup le minimalisme
ça va aussi avec
avec
de la cosméto l'hygiène etc oui je dis
cela sans moi il se dit ça en fait je
sais qu'il veut se moquer de moi mais il
dit ça parce qu'en fait ce que je sais
c'est un mec plus ta clique on le sait
tous
toi et moi on sait ce qu'il fait sur sa
chaîne bref je me lave à l'eau depuis un
an et leur j'ai sorti une vidéo sur le
sujet où je fais mon bilan est
effectivement c'est une forme de mini
maxi juste pour dire je vais la mettre
dedans on vient dans la description
cette vidéo est en fait le truc c'est
qu'avant j'utilisais utiliser des gels
douches des trucs comme ça j'ai commencé
à rentrer dans mon délire bio écolo
machin donc j'ai supprimé le plastique
ce qui crée des déchets sur tout ce qui
est technique et j'ai eu la question de
est ce que je me lavais du savon ou pas
parce que ça aurait pu être une réponse
intéressante mais quand j'ai acheté mon
savon je devais vérifier au niveau
d'étiquetage c'était un vrai bon savon
et compagnie ça va très vite sous les
mois dès que c'est un peu compliqué ça
me fatigue j'avais la solution me laver
à l'eau ça avait l'air cool j'ai tenté
pendant trois mois je n'ai pas dit à mon
mari donc je voulais savoir si je puis
ou pas je ne fume pas je ne pus pas il
s'en est pas rendu compte
donc j'ai fait ça pendant un an et
maintenant je continue et c'est trop
bien parce qu'en fait dans tous les
aspects de ta vie tu peut simplifier les
choses qu'on a tendance à tout le temps
compliquée merci beaucoup à vous de voir
regarder cette vidéo merci à notre pote
raj qui fallait de pied de caméra et
merci encore une fois à toi les ti
n'hésitez pas à visiter sa chaîne y
allait bien qu'il faut dans la
description vous pouvez aussi mettre un
pouce en l'air si ça vous a plu et puis
le mental box est toujours une idée par
jour pendant un an du 1er janvier au 30
min oui le mental blog pas la chaîne
donc rendez vous demain à 17h tchaourou
l'abcès
gala
[Musique]